come molti di voi sapranno sul web è
pieno di interviste che che mi hanno
fatto al tg al telegiornale cose quando
l'esplosione ha fatto un miliardo di
interviste sono anche come si tiene un
microfono
vorrei fare una reaction alle interviste
che mi hanno fatto il pieno
inizia male la piu vista in assoluto del
mondo che è stata questa al tg1 è la mia
prima intervista i tempi come lo schermo
del tg e tipo una roba devastante anno
sdoppiato il mio armadio 280 milioni di
click rosti capelli non è che potrà
farne di più di click insomma è appena
stato premiato per aver superato il
milione di fans parliamo di un
diciannovenne di torino che è diventato
un vero e proprio divo del web grazie ai
suoi video su youtube
valentina bisti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono qua vigenza
le invenzioni di lorraine cos'è sta
cos'è la canzone che c'era di sottofondo
ve lo giuro su dio non era questa l'anno
remixata per metterla al tg
probabilmente per problemi di copyright
sentiti che musiche hanno inventato ma
cos'è il testo pro profondo tra l'altro
va ebrei meroni di lorenzo ostuni in
arte fani j sono tutte in questi video
girati in casa clip ironiche che lo
hanno trasformato a soli 19 anni in una
star del web
osannata come fosse una rockstar
[Musica]
madonna dalla qualità delle riprese
sembra che sia un video del 1980 di
lorenzo sempre pronta a riceverlo eccolo
eccolo celebrità sempre una parola molto
bravo parliamo di shampoo invece che
dice pure il suo canale youtube ha
registrato 1 milione di iscritti
la sua passione sono i videogiochi si
filma nelle sue reazioni spontanee
questa frase mi ricordo che ai tempi un
sacco di haters si avevano aver evocato
la tourette perché tipo fa vj spontaneo
qua dove il ragazzo bellissimo che balla
mangiate mila l'anziano che sta col
brodino che guarda al ticino è e si vede
st scena del tg ragazzo tizio bellissimo
che balla che poi spunta un tizio nel
riquadro con lasko una scatola in testa
pensa cosa mai può aver capito il
cristiano e ogni suo genoa ogni fase
inventata lì per lì sono diventati per i
suoi giovani sono canzoni quotidiano la
giornata video grazie abbiate paura di
ciò che state per vedere ok
[Musica]
sparate in diretta nazionale e la sua
cameretta farà bene per primi le parole
sono in libertà ma di fronte alle nostre
telecamere loro infortuni a un timido
ragazzo come tanti altri
grazie nell'intervista un saluto al tg1
da fa vigenti wow tg2
quindi dal tg1 passiamo tg2 rai di
allora siccome abbiamo detto che c'è a
vjc 6 lorenzo o studi mi sento
buongiorno qua buongiorno allora intanto
ti vediamo perfetto come tu fai tutti i
tuoi video buongiorno quel giorno si sia
ormai questa è diventata la location
qualche pratica ticamente dove sei
arrivato a stanza a distanza di due
metri quadrati ma è sempre stata questa
quindi allora vediamo un po lorenzo che
no no io sono all'arco sono luglio stato
uno dei suoi video che è andato più
forte no vediamolo gis a vederlo così
hanno mandato reagan uno ricoverato per
una no no vi prego non mi voglio vedere
se rochester o ma non può essere andato
sul tg rica intero per fare appunto the
box central altri canti pezzo di pane
bastava non può essere andata in tv
nazionale ragala mi rifiuto o troppo
kringe e khrin gino inviando
[Musica]
attendo
no ragazzi sono stanchi non siate
pazienti che fa guarda con che faccia
sto guardando questa cosa ti prego
vannucci di rientro in camera lancia
miccoli con cibi pony fine la mia
sofferenza guardali felice faccio
lorenzo previsto visto che avesse una
mano davanti agli occhi e rito mio dio
quello non solo un professionista del
ballo questa mattina al tg2
proseguendo abbiamo scuote questa è
stata una le interviste più belle in
assoluto perché le domande non erano per
nulla scontate anzi ti è mai capitato
invece di girare un video ma poi di
cancellarlo perché non ti piaceva 1 neri
è soddisfatto del risultato
non so quante volte mi è successa questa
cosa no in realtà ho registrato dei
video mentre c'era la pioggia quindi un
fulmine ha colpito casa mia si è spento
il computer fa è successo di tutto
ma quando vai in giro mette i cappelli
che metti nei video girato li mettono i
video perché ogni tanto quando non c'è
voglia di pettinarmi devo fare un video
cioè capelli così poi ragazzi e questa
roba è vero i capelli che ho sempre
messo nei video ai tempi che mettevo li
mettevo veramente perché quando hai
capelli a minchia cappelli che mettevo
ai tempi proprio li mettevo apposta per
evitare che voi vedete quanto facevano
schifo i capelli in quel momento c'era
per evitare di tutto sto casino e poi
tra i momenti più alti di interviste c'è
ovviamente gira un pochino
ok vice elfi per scuote la testa che lo
giuro ragazzi e lo dico ancora oggi è
stata la più bella intervista che mi
abbiano mai fatto mi hanno chiesto
robben non scontate quindi come iniziato
come mai ti chiami fa vj cosa ne
pensavano i tuoi genitori quando
iniziata fa sta roba i tuoi amici dove
senti ancora queste domande proprio
della serie ti devo fate le domande ti
faccio quanto guadagni solita roba
invece scuote mi aveva fatto delle
domande precise che non mi aveva mai
fatto nessuno quindi è stato una figata
ma questo atteggiamento abbastanza
cartoonesco mi sembra anche la fisicità
diciamo che è molto allineato ancora
questa avevo dei capelli decenti
incredibile flashback.c andato anche
show mendes a deejay chiama italia
ho fatto la stessa intervista che ha
fatto cio mendes un po prima e lui avevo
i capelli un po più ordinati dei miei
però come chicca ragazzi devo farvi
assolutamente vedere la mia primissima
intervista perché mi ricordo qual è
stata la mia prima proprio la prima
intervista la prima volta e manomesso un
microfono così tempo e apprezzate la mia
bellezza proprio estetica in questo
video apprezzate dai temi c'è il martino
siamo qui insieme a renzo inattesa vj
che è venuto a città delle stelle il
centro commerciale di luigi di ascoli
pieno di nintendo è quello che sembra ci
sia parecchia allora ero proprio a mio
agio minchia stavo proprio bene volevo
bene sono sciolti avuto una grande
popolarità in pochissimo tempo
non penso di avere
perché mi diverte mi fa piacere che la
gente si diverta parlano i miei video
cioè sono contento di giornalista a fare
la storia
persone che cosa che mi sia come dico
mezzo milione dei tempi avevo 500.000
iscritti per sentirmi parte di quelli
che vanno milioni di iscritti dicevo io
non ho 500 metri tira un mezzo milione
po come le giovani mamme che invece di
dire che il figlio a tre anni dicono già
36 mesi
era una cosa molto triste si ve lo
assicuro tutti ma che testa ma in che
forme c se tu fai
ok che ci siete questo è il mio contorno
guardate la mia sagoma di pace 1 non
vede la faccia vede solo sta roba che
cosa può pensare che sei un po il kraken
ve lo giuro nome non mi stancherò mai di
guardare i miei capelli come era un
tempo sembra che ci spera avessi l'olio
dentro non so i martinsicuresi è
innanzitutto il sì ma ci sono mai stato
martinsicuro che cazzo di però posso
giurare su quello che volete a
martinsicuro non ci sono mai stato
quindi questa frase è una menzogna il
salute coe martinsicuresi
sono sicuro che innanzitutto è
bellissima cena mi dà la possibilità di
parlare anche un pubblico un po più
grandi e zona adocchiando del terreno
vedete se c'è qualcuno se ascoltate bene
questa intervista di crapis di
sottofondo ci sono io che urlo ciao
mamma e ve lo giuro ed esso è riuscito a
sentirlo fanno impazzire comunque
arrivati fino a questo punto c'è
un'ultima cosa che volevo dirvi io ho
lasciato come ciliegina sulla torta la
vera e unica intervista numero 1 che ho
fatto c'è questa proprio quella che mi
rappresenta con l'api seria ed io
concludo quel video vi lascio all'ultima
intervista che senza reaction assaporate
voi quindi io vi invito ragazzi se vi
dove è piaciuto a lasciare un commento è
un mi piace e se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
buona visione ragazzi oltre 4 milioni di
iscritti lei è a tutti gli effetti lo
youtube era più seguito d'italia si
immagina marchiati dipana breve se fosse
anche intelligente simpatico e simona
l'area l'esperienza che ha maturato
nell'ambito digitale influenza molto
anche la sua vita reale è vero che una
volta finito di fare sesso ricorre
sempre alla rimozione sicura
dell'hardware me beh sono decine di
categorie diverse di youtube ne esiste
anche qualunque non composta da gente di
una voglia di fare un punto nella vita
come lei
mi ha scritto è stato amante loriso
abbiamo senza tuffo da grandi numeri che
arrivano prende responsabilità
questo a me pensato di utilizzare il suo
potere mediatico per fare del bene alla
comunità
magari andando per un periodo a fare
video e ruanda risparmiandoci entusiasmo
cvmp nativo andava dell'europa su come
saluta il suo pubblico francese
ciao ragazzi ce n'è una domanda vi
raccomando preparare la lingua
procedevano messaggio carino a trl ciao
ragazzi di allora lo stesso
[Musica]